King Joffrey has FINALLY got his comeuppance.
But WHO did it?
Let's look at who was in a position to OFF
Joff!
Hey fellow Game of Thrones fans, it's JAN
here for Flicks And The City.
What is it about Game of Thrones and whacking
people at weddings?
First, the Starks got it in the neck in season
3's RED Wedding.
And then Joffrey got all choked up in season
4's PURPLE Wedding.
Ok, so no one died at Tyrion and Sansa's wedding,
but it wasn't EXACTLY a barrel of laughs now,
was it?
And don't forget Jaime Lannister's gentle
reminder to Loras Tyrell that if Loras ACTUALLY
married Cersei she'd murder the Knight of
Flowers in his sleep!
Anyone would think George RR Martin had something
against marriage!
Anyway, the BIG question the Purple Wedding
left us with was: Who Killed Joffrey?
One of TV's biggest whodunits since The Simpsons'
Who Shot Mr Burns?
or Dallas's Who Shot JR?!
So, just who are Westeros's Most Wanted?
Well, for once, it's just about everyone apart
from Cersei!
Let's look at the suspects.
YES, Tyrion has been accused of killing his
nephew by Cersei, who says Joffrey pointed
at his uncle as he died.
And YES, he does have PLENTY of reasons to
LOATHE Joffrey – not LEAST the relentless
humiliation he suffered during the wedding
festivities, including the sick spectacle
of the War of the 5 Kings.
And YES, he did have PLENTY of opportunity
as the King's Cupbearer at the wedding.
And Sansa DOES flee the scene of the crime,
MAYBE because she knew what her husband had
done, or MAYBE because Tyrion had arranged
for her to get out of harm's way in case he
was caught.
BUT, we all know that Tyrion has an unfortunate
history of being accused of crimes he didn't
commit!
Remember Catelyn accusing him of pushing Bran
out of the tower?
And LYSA accusing him of murdering her husband
Jon ARRYN, the King's Hand prior to Ned Stark?
Ok, so he DID tell his squire Podrick to pay
the dwarf entertainers after the wedding,
adding that ‘We'll have to find another
way to thank the King.'
But although Tyrion is small in stature, he's
big in brain, which means he'd be WAY too
clever to put himself so obviously in the
firing line.
Had he ACTUALLY done the deed, I don't think
he'd be standing round picking up the incriminating
goblet after the event.
But with mother of madness Cersei on his case,
let's just say he's gonna need a good lawyer
or alternately, someone a bit skilful in a
skirmish to fight for him in a trial-by-combat
situation just like Bronn did at the Eyrie.
And so to the bride.
Margaery Tyrell CERTAINLY knows her way around
the POLITICS of POWER.
She married Renly Baratheon, DESPITE knowing
he was the LOVER of her brother Loras.
She won over Joffrey with flattery when Loras
asked him to marry her in repayment for the
Tyrells helping the Lannisters win Blackwater.
And she's worn her "I-heart-Joffrey" T-shirt
well ever since then, with a little slip in
episode 1 of season 4, when she commented
sarcastically to her grandmother Olenna that
if Joffrey chose her wedding necklace it'd
PROBABLY be made of "DEAD SPARROW heads".
From both Margaery's own experience and Sansa's,
she was FULLY aware of the nature of the BEAST
she was marrying.
Maybe she thought that if she WERE going to
throw herself WILLINGLY into the lions' den,
it would be wise to make sure the one with
the most VICIOUS BITE was out of the way.
YES, she's been able to control Joffrey up
to THIS point, getting him to wave to his
people and give his leftovers to the poor.
But how LONG would it be before he'd get BEYOND
her control, as happened to Cersei?
I mean, just look at Joffrey's sick re-enactment
of the War of the 5 Kings, and his treatment
of Tyrion at the feast.
Given both real-life AND Game of Thrones history,
with Joffrey dead, it's likely Margaery would
wed his much-better-behaved brother Tommen.
Game, set and match, Margaery, then.
Oh, and she certainly had her CHANCE to dispense
with the malicious monarch.
After all, she was beside him throughout the
wedding festivities, handed him his gold goblet,
and even fed him his pie.
AND she DIDN'T rush to his side to help him,
like Cersei did, as he lay dying on the floor.
Also, was Joffrey pointing at Tyrion as he
died or was he ACTUALLY pointing at Margaery?!
Plus, getting rid of Cersei's pride and joy
would doubtless give Margaery a bit of ADDED
revenge on her mother-in-law for her Rains
of Castamere threat last season!
So, Margaery's had TWO husbands now and BOTH
of them have died in mysterious circumstances.
We know she wasn't behind Renly's death, of
course.
Still, if I were the THIRD husband-to-be,
I wouldn't like THOSE odds!
The Tyrells, however, ALWAYS seem to come
up smelling of roses
Could granddaddy Tywin have tired of Joffrey?
As terrifying as Tywin is, wouldn't Joffrey
only cower before him for so long?
Could he REALLY have continued to order the
King to his chambers once he was a married
man?
Perhaps, Tywin thought it was time for a more
LIKEABLE Lannister to take the Iron Throne,
and therefore make his life and position as
the Hand easier.
But MOST IMPORTANTLY the new blood would be
PLIABLE.
Step forward, Tommen, it's your turn!
In fact, if you look CAREFULLY, you can see
Tywin protects Tommen from seeing Joffrey
die.
And how would Tywin have done it?
Well, the man's a master of machinations,
and it's not like he doesn't have EXPERIENCE
with this sort of wedding, now, is it?
Perhaps the new sword Tywin gifted Joffrey
for his wedding was actually laced with poison.
So, when Joffrey used it to cut the wedding
pie, it poisoned the piece he ate.
The dead dove we see in the pie was doubtless
caused by Joffrey striking it with his sword,
but it's still an interesting way to foreshadow
his death.
But wouldn't OTHERS have eaten the pie at
the feast and therefore been affected too?
Well, yes, BUT we never actually SEE anyone
else eat the pie – though we DO see Olenna
and Tywin with a forkful of something.
But SURELY as King, Joffrey would be the FIRST
to scoff down his piece, and once you've seen
the King drop dead after eating HIS pie, I'm
guessing that might put you off yours!
And remember, Joffrey's new sword, the Widow's
Wail, as he names it, was actually melted
down from Ned Stark's sword Ice.
And wouldn't that be a delightful irony – the
kind that Tywin would doubtless enjoy – to
know that Joffrey died by the same blade that
killed Ned Stark?
The sword may NOT have caused a widow's wail
THIS time, but it certainly led a MOTHER to
mourn.
The Red Priestess is DEFINITELY dark and full
of terrors, but was it REALLY Miss Scarlett
with the black magic in the dining room/bedroom?
Let's look at the evidence.
She's been involved in a death by poisoned
wine before.
Remember Maester Cressen in season 2 who tried
to poison Melisandre?
Well, they both drank from the SAME cup of
poisoned wine, but Melisandre was fine while
Cressen keeled over, blood pouring from his
nose.
Now, where have I seen that lately?
Then there's Melisandre's attempt to show
Stannis Baratheon the POWER of king's blood,
using the blood of Gendry, Robert Baratheon's
BASTARD son.
She had Stannis throw leeches fat with Gendry's
blood into a fire while naming three USURPERS
he wanted DEAD.
The men he named were Robb Stark, Balon Greyjoy,
and Joffrey Baratheon.
Well, Robb and Joffrey are already dead.
SO, is Stannis-sandre the dark force behind
Joffrey's earthly departure?
Or was it just coincidence?
I bet Balon Greyjoy hopes so!
Sansa CERTAINLY had MORE than enough reasons
to do away with the King.
He beheaded her father in front of her, DESPITE
agreeing to show him mercy, and later forced
her to look at Ned's head on a spike.
When she initially refused, he had one of
his men strike her.
He threatened her with a crossbow in front
of the whole court, before ordering her to
be beaten.
And his lies about the incident with Arya
and butcher's boy Mycah led to Sansa's direwolf
Lady being killed.
Not to mention his persistent jibes at his
wedding about her dead family, and that disgusting
display of Robb Stark's death in the War of
5 dwarf Kings.
The list is endless!
So, who'd blame Sansa for killing the King?
No one!
And she certainly had the opportunity.
Remember when Joffrey kicked his gold goblet
away from Tyrion to humiliate his new cupbearer,
well, it went under Sansa's table.
And it was Sansa who picked it up and handed
it back to Tyrion.
Perhaps that gave her JUST enough time to
secrete something SINISTER in the goblet.
AND there's the fact that people who flee
the scene of a crime tend to look a little
bit guilty!
But, she DOES seem a little surprised when
Dontos turns up to take her away and, let's
face it, she hasn't exactly displayed the
same killer instinct as her sister Arya.
Yes, he's got motive – remember Joffrey
was going to have him drowned in wine in season
2, until Sansa and The Hound intervened, telling
the King it'd be bad luck to kill someone
on his name day?
And when Dontos performed at the wedding as
the King's fool, Joffrey egged on the crowd
to pelt him with food.
Plus, Dontos was there ready to whisk off
Sansa once the King hit the deck, telling
her that if she wanted to live, she had to
leave.
And THEN there's the small matter of the NECKLACE
Dontos gave Sansa in episode 1 of season 4
why was he QUITE so insistent she take it?
Do YOU believe that family heirloom story?
He WAS at the wedding festivities too, so
maybe he could have interfered with the feast.
After all, he DOES know his way round a barrel
of wine.
But surely, Dontos is too much of a drunken
fool to orchestrate the death of the King
by himself, right?
Ah, Petyr Baelish, one of the most dangerous
and least trustworthy men in Westeros.
A man whose influence is felt EVERYWHERE.
And YET, he's been conspicuous by his ABSENCE
in episodes 1 and 2 of season 4.
Ok, so his ship is SUPPOSED to have left for
the Vale of AIR-RIN at the end of season 3.
But, just because he doesn't SEEM to be around,
doesn't mean events are beyond his control.
After all, like Varys, he has his spies.
For example, male prostitute Olyvar, who,
after sleeping with Loras in season 3, and
found out about the Tyrells' plan to marry
Loras to Sansa.
And THIS season, Olyvar's been keeping Oberyn
MARTELL entertained, and Littlefinger informed
too no doubt.
SO, did Littlefinger have a HAND in Joffrey's
death?
Well, he's certainly DEVIOUS enough to do
so, and he's given himself a GREAT alibi by
NOT attending the wedding.
It wouldn't be the FIRST time he's tried to
frame Tyrion Lannister either.
Who was it, after all, who told Catelyn Stark
that the dagger used in Bran's attempted assassination
ACTUALLY belonged to Tyrion and that Tyrion
had won it from Littlefinger in a bet?
EXACTLY!
But WHY would he slay the sovereign?
Think back to that conversation Littlefinger
and Varys had about the realm in season 3.
You know the one where Littlefinger says that
‘Chaos is a ladder.
Many who try to climb it fail.
And some are given the chance to climb but
they refuse.
They cling to the realm or the gods or love,
illusions.
Only the ladder is real.
The climb is all there is.'
Obviously, Littlefinger is an aficionado of
chaos, and the more chaos the merrier.
And a monarch meeting his maker is PRETTY
high up there when it comes to creating chaos.
Chaos which would doubtless create MANY opportunities
for Littlefinger to climb higher and higher
up that ladder.
Just as the chaos of war allowed him to rise
to Lord of Harrenhal, after he arranged for
the Tyrells to support the Lannisters at Blackwater
and beyond.
SO, what would Littlefinger hope to gain SPECIFICALLY
from Joffrey's death?
Well, if Dontos was whisking off Sansa to
Littlefinger, then Littlefinger would control
what MOST characters believe to be the ONLY
remaining STARK KEY to the North.
Which would mean more power to Littlefinger's
elbow – or should that be finger?
Anyway
He's already TRIED to take Sansa away before,
though she declined.
Don't forget that Ros warned Shae and Varys
about Littlefinger having his eye on the eldest
Stark daughter – and we all know how THAT
ended for Ros.
THIS time though, Sansa had little choice
about leaving as it might not be long before
the finger of suspicion was pointed at her
for Joffrey's death.
And remember: Littlefinger was infatuated
with Sansa's mother Catelyn, but his love
was unrequited.
Wouldn't he therefore RELISH controlling Cat's
beautiful daughter Sansa, and it would give
him a bit of revenge just like when he betrayed
Cat's husband Ned?
SO, how did he do it?
Well, where do you think drunken Dontos got
that necklace from?
And WHY did he ACTUALLY give it to Sansa?
Couldn't the REAL point of the necklace have
been to smuggle poison into the wedding without
raising suspicion?
And if the plan WERE discovered, Sansa would
make the perfect patsy.
There's certainly seems to be NO limit to
what Littlefinger will do to get what he wants.
As Varys told Olenna Tyrell, "he would see
this country burn if he could be king of the
ashes".
Oh boy, the more you think about it, the more
it seems that Petyr Baelish's fingerprints
are ALL over this!
But he would have needed someone RELIABLE
at the wedding to make sure the poison ended
up in the right place
NOW, did you notice that during the wedding
ceremony when the Septon says ‘cursed be
he who would seek to tear them asunder', we
get a lovely shot FOCUSED on Olenna and Loras
Tyrell, Oberyn Martell, and Pycelle behind
Margaery and Joffrey?
Hmmm.
Intriguing.
And so to the Tyrell matriarch.
We know Olenna's a woman of both wit and wealth.
She isn't afraid to speak her mind.
She's shrewd enough to be able to deal with
Tywin Lannister, and like him, she's a master
of political power games.
But why would she want to bump off her grandson-in-law?
Well, she's obviously not impressed with Joffrey's
behaviour, to say the least
Sansa called him a ‘monster' when Olenna
asked her what she thought of him.
And did you SEE the look on Olenna's face
at the end of the dwarf entertainment?
A smart cookie like Olenna could see that
Margaery would ONLY be able to control the
King so far.
With Joffrey GONE, Margaery would be set to
marry the much-more-malleable next-in-line
to the Iron Throne, Tommen.
Therefore Olenna could keep Margaery away
from Joffrey's crossbow while STILL joining
the royal bloodline, which would help House
Tyrell grow strong.
So, how did she do it?
Well, Olenna was definitely fiddling with
something in her hands as she spoke to Tywin
on the way to the feast.
Could it have been a little something to add
to Joffrey's wine?
But she's too clever to risk it being seen
like that, isn't she?
She ALSO makes a point of touching Sansa's
hair and neck as she consoles her about her
brother Robb's death, telling here that ‘War
is war, but killing a man at a wedding, horrid.
What sort of MONSTER would do such a thing?'
Olenna could have taken this opportunity to
pick up something previously planted on Sansa
to do in Joffrey.
Drunken fool Dontos DID insist Sansa take
his family necklace as a thank-you for saving
his life, and she's CLEARLY wearing it at
the wedding.
But what's this?
Is that a stone missing from the necklace
after Olenna fussed over Sansa?
I think it is!
And what's that little CLINK we hear and that
little motion of the arm we see as Olenna
walks past Margaery's table?
Did she pass the poison stone from Sansa's
necklace on to Margaery, OR into Joffrey's
goblet?
So, Olenna could be in cahoots with Littlefinger.
She'd certainly be a reliable person to have
on the ground and the Tyrells have much to
gain.
Olenna also suggests that Sansa should visit
Highgarden – just as Margaery did in season
3 – perhaps to make sure she's out of harm's
way, not only from Littlefinger this time,
but also from anyone who MIGHT think Sansa
was involved in a plot to murder her former
fiancé.
Or POSSIBLY to incriminate her OR her husband
Tyrion.
When no one does anything to aid the choking
Joffrey, Olenna DOES order the wedding guests
to help their king.
Was this a genuine desire to help?
Or a clever way to take suspicion from herself?
If Olenna was behind the plot, all this would
come with a delicious side-serving of retaliation
on Tywin for forcing Loras to marry Cersei,
which scuppered Olenna's plans to marry him
to Sansa in season 3.
Season 4 marks the first time we've seen Mace
Tyrell on screen.
Lord of Highgarden and head of one of the
RICHEST families in Westeros, Mace was keen
on increasing his family's prestige by wedding
his daughter Margaery to Joffrey.
SURELY that means he WOULDN'T have knocked
off his new son-in-law then.
Add to that the fact that, according to his
mother Olenna, he's a "ponderous oaf" who
places food above fighting, and we seem to
be erasing him from the list of suspects.
But hold on, his wedding gift to Joffrey was
a gold cup, right?
YES, but it WASN'T the gold goblet Joff was
drinking from when he croaked.
Still, when Mace gave Joff his wedding gift,
he DID say, "may you drink deep and live long."
Well, Joffrey certainly drank deep – he
wasn't quite so good at the living long part
though!
So, was this just a case of the show foreshadowing
Joffrey's death, or was Mace in on the murderous
plan?
He WAS sat next to Joffrey during the wedding
gift presentations.
Could he have poisoned the King then with
a slow-acting potion?
Is it possible that "fathead" Mace has more
upstairs than Olenna gives him credit for?
But what about a motive?
Well, his motive would be the same as Olenna's,
that is, to protect Margaery while keeping
the crown.
Hmmmm...
And now, the brother of the bride.
Loras was possibly in earshot when Joffrey
called Renly a "deviant" at his wedding feast
and told Brienne he'd knight the man who put
a sword through his dead father's brother.
Add to that the butt-naked dwarf running about
as Renly in Joffrey's vile entertainment,
which led to Loras leaving the wedding table
in disgust, AND the fact that Joffrey told
Margaery in season 3 that he was considering
making homosexuality punishable by death,
and brother Tyrell has some POSSIBLE motives.
But Loras does make a bit of a habit of storming
off from weddings – remember Tyrion and
Sansa's wedding where Olenna made a comment
on his impending marriage to Cersei?
Also, if Loras DIDN'T do the deed himself,
but his family, say Margaery or Olenna did,
do you think they'd have let Loras in on it?
Probably not!
After all, he gave the game away to Littlefinger's
spy and prostitute Olyvar about their plans
to marry Loras off to Sansa, thus ruining
that Tyrell plot.
So, Loras is probably OFF the list of suspects.
Since we first met Oberyn Martell, aka The
Red Viper, in episode 1 of season 4, it's
been PRETTY obvious that he's NOT EXACTLY
the Lannisters' biggest fan.
Of course, he's NOT the ONLY one in the show
who could DEFINITELY live without hearing
The Rains of Castamere, but he has harboured
a long-standing grudge against House Lannister
for their part in the death of his sister
Elia and her kids.
Remember that Elia – who was married to
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen – was raped and
killed by Gregor Clegane, aka The Mountain,
when the Lannisters sacked King's Landing
just before Robert Baratheon became king.
So, Oberyn is not only a lover but ALSO a
fighter and one who appears pretty intent
on toppling The Mountain for his crimes.
But why kill Joffrey?
Why not just knock off The Mountain?
An eye for an eye maybe?
Maybe the King's death is just the start!
Oberyn blames Tywin and his family for the
deaths of Elia and her children, as he believes
Gregor would NOT have acted without Tywin's
consent.
And as Oberyn told Tyrion when they first
met, "the Lannisters aren't the only ones
who pay their debts."
I bet the Lannisters wouldn't want to be on
the receiving end of the Red Viper's VENONMOUS
bite!
Then there was that verbal sparring session
between Cersei, Tywin, Oberyn and his lover
Ellaria Sand at the wedding, where they traded
mutual insults.
That culminated in what COULD be viewed as
a veiled threat by Oberyn against Cersei's
daughter Myrcella, who was shipped off to
Dorne in season 2 to be married to Oberyn's
nephew:
This is what Oberyn said to Cersei: "In some
places, the highborn frown upon those of low
birth.
In other places, the rape and murder of women
and children is considered distasteful.
What a fortunate thing for you, former Queen
Regent, that your daughter Myrcella has been
sent to live in the latter sort of place."
Oooh!
So, could he have been helped by Ellaria in
his plot to rid the realm of Joffrey?
Yes, he's Joffrey's real father.
But does that really matter in a world where
siblings sleep together, brother kills brother,
and father scorns son?
It's not like Joffrey wasn't known for getting
RIGHT under people's skin!
Just look at how he taunted Jaime in episode
1 of season 4, saying that Jaime had never
done anything worthy of being recorded in
the history book of the Kingsguard.
And look how depressed Jaime is in episode
2 of season 4 about being unable to fight
since losing his sword hand.
But, come on, would Jaime really have offed
Joffrey?
After all, he's actually the first one to
go to Joffrey's side when the young King falls
to the ground.
Fatherly instinct or just doing his job?
His position as a MAESTER, a man of science
and medicine among other things, means he
has access to all sorts of potions and poisons.
And Cersei's needling of him at the wedding
festivities – telling him that his every
breath annoys her – wouldn't EXACTLY have
put him in a GOOD mood.
But then again, he WAS sent away from the
wedding by Cersei, who ordered him to tell
the kitchens to give the leftovers from the
feast to the kennels.
So, that means he was out of the way and therefore
couldn't have done it, right?
Not exactly, as we DO later see Pycelle sitting
opposite Varys during the mock tournament.
Could he have been involved then in the murderous
plot?
Ok, we all know what a wily character Pycelle
is, pretending he's a bit deaf or a bit old
and creaky, as the situation requires, and
then leaping to life when no one's around.
But TYWIN'S on to his little game, and Pycelle
seems WAY too intent on keeping his head down,
and toadying up to whoever's in power to risk
his neck killing the King.
It's no wonder he's been a Grand Maester – the
King's personal maester – for so many years.
Did you notice how uncomfortable Varys looked
during the wedding festivities?
Most of the guests were clapping when Margaery
announced leftovers from the feast were going
to the poor, when the dwarf entertainers arrived,
when dwarf Robb Stark was killed in front
of Sansa, and when dwarf Joffrey humped Robb's
direwolf head.
But Varys didn't join in; he just looked rather
on edge.
Now, of course Joffrey's vile entertainment
would be enough to make anyone uneasy, but
isn't Varys often better at hiding what he
thinks than that?
Is it possible the Spider spun a wily web
to kill Joffrey?
Judging by his refusal to lie to the Lannisters
about Shae, when Tyrion asks him to, it doesn't
SEEM likely he'd have the balls to off Joff.
So maybe his unease at the wedding was ACTUALLY
down to his knowledge that someone else had
a plot in motion.
After all, he DOES have his little birds.
So, who done it?
What do YOU think?
Tell us in the comments below.
And while you're at it, remember to like our
video and subscribe to Flicks And The City
for TONS more Game of Thrones reviews and
interviews.
Just before we leave you, let's remind ourselves
of the wise words of Dwight Schrute from The
Office:
‘It's NEVER the person you MOST suspect.
It's also NEVER the person you LEAST suspect,
since anyone with HALF a brain would suspect
them the MOST.
Therefore, I know the killer to be
the person I most MEDIUM suspect.'
So, who do YOU most MEDIUM suspect?
And remember, if you're not watching Jan G
on GoT, you know nothin'!